I identify with a lot of Bernie's ideas
maybe their implementation I'm more
flexible on I'll give you one example
Medicare for all
one way of trying to get health care to
everybody which Bernie's very big on is
you take the current Medicare program
you just eliminate the age limit make it
available to everybody pay for it
through taxation interesting however I'm
open to other models if they get
everybody health care that is
good quality and affordable Singapore
has an interesting model Germany has an
interesting model I am I am more
agnostic about how we do it than just
saying let's expand Medicare whether
that puts me to the right of of Bernie I
don't I don't know but I'm not like
exactly right there on it has to be
Medicare for all yeah that's more of uh
that's more just flexibility versus
dogmatism so I don't know if that puts
you to the left or to the right I don't
even